hallo klickzom hallo
axelbosse meine Frage ist
wie machst du das eigentlich
ähm macht ihr eure Songs selber also
eure Texte selber weil in vier Jahr in
sech Jahren so so viele Alben
rauszubringen vier an der ganzen Zahl
andere Bands machen eins und 3 Jahen
ähm
kriture Texte selber kriture Songs
selber sind die Texte von euch aus
realen Gegebenheiten oder sind die
selbst
erfunden so wie macht ihr das gib bitte
gibt mir Tipps ber weil in meiner Band
z.B wir haben furchtbar Probleme neue
Songs zu kreieren und weichen natich auf
Cover Version von irgendwas anderem aus
ob du mir dann bitte ein Tipp geben
könntest danke
Ciao okay hier ist meine Antwort also ja
ja ich schreib das alles selber und ich
ich braucht da so keine Hilfe und ich
habe auch schon lange nicht mehr
gecovert ich habe aber allerdings früher
schon mal gecovert
und der Tipp für mich an deine Band wäre
eigentlich na ich finde ich finde das
Covern erstmal gar nicht so schlecht ne
weil man covert ja weil man erstmal Bock
hat Mucke zu machen und da kann man ja
ganz Manchester und ganz Seattle auch
erstmal noch mal einmal
durchcovern vielleicht kommt man da so
auf Ideen und beim Songs schreiben
glaube ich
schon dass ich jetzt an deiner Stelle
mal ich weiß auch nicht was du für ein
Instrument spielst aber bis wenn du
jetzt der Sänger und der Gitarrist bist
würde ich eben gucken dass du dir
vielleicht ein aus der Band aussuch also
nicht mit allen da zusammen bist sonder
einen aussuchst vielleicht den Typen
deines Vertrauens und ihr euch hinsetzt
und einfach noch mal probiert und ich
würde eben vorschlagen dass man es eben
textmäßig vielleicht so anfängt dass man
sich erstmal ein Thema Sucht also ich
würde mir vielleicht bei euch beiden
vorstellen wenn ihr jetzt auf englisch
singt z.B oder auf
Deutsch wäre mein Tipp glaube ich für
den Anfang
erstmal was über eine Busreise zu singen
mit
z.B
drei Rentnern die vorne sitzen ein
Busfahrer der vielleicht drei Promille
zu viel hat und ihr sitzt so hinten und
erzählt euch so ein bisschen was und
dein Kumpel hat noch Liebeskummer oder
so das wäre eiglich ein ganz guter
Anfang das heißt mir hilft es immer sehr
wenn ich so wenn da gar nichts ist und
ich auch nichts habe was mich so gerade
betrifft oder berührt mich irgendwie so
reinzudenken und ansonsten würde ich
noch mal so ein bisschen gucken was die
anderen auch so machen also vielleicht
mal in NAD surf Album hören und so ein
Song wie teas Bones einfach mal so
übersetzen und mal gucken was die so zu
erzählen haben und da vielleicht so
Ansätze finden wie man weitermachen kann
blablabla aber ansonsten wünsche ich
ganz viel Glück und du siehst irgendwie
aus als wärst du auch noch nicht 25 und
ich glaube da da kannst du einfach noch
mal so ein bisschen auf die Wiese also
weißt was ich meine aber auf die Wiese
gehen und noch mal so ein bisschen
machen da kommt bestimmt schon was gutes
bei raus viel Erfolg
tschüss